And in terms of
looking at the idea itself-
>> Yeah.
>> What would be, if you had two ideas,
what would you look in terms of this
is a better idea than the other idea?
>> For me, it changes.
I don't think I can just
say this idea or that idea.
I think one of the things I really look
for is someone building a product or
a company that's focused on
a market that's growing, or
that will grow because
that product exists.
I don't really love products that are
entering super mature markets because,
at that point, startups lose
a lot of their nimbleness and
a lot of their advantages.
Because if you're going
into a mature market,
basically what gets you noticed
is advertising dollars.
And you're just fighting for
a slice of a pre-existing pie.
But if you build something that's
going to cause a market to grow or
building something for a market that
is growing, you're fighting for
a slice of an ever expanding pie.
And that is so much more interesting.
It let's you play around more.
The rules aren't written.
There's all these things you can do.
So I like those kinds of things more.
But that's not to say that there aren't
great businesses to be built in mature
markets, as well.
And it also depends on how you
think about what's a mature market,
what's not.
And I also like companies
that make me think honestly,
that make me look at a problem
from a brand new perspective.
Something that makes me say, huh,
I didn't realize you could do that.
>> Very Cool.
>> You know,
and that's tough to do, right,
because we spend all day thinking about
ideas and thinking about new companies.
But when you see one of those,
that's the kind of thing that
you get really excited about.
>> So, what would be an example
of an early stage market versus
a mature market?
>> So, mature market, and
this is kind of a silly example, but
junk food or something like that.
It's like a pretty mature market, right?
So, if a company came to us and said I'm
going to make a new kind of potato chip.
Now, there's a bunch of reasons
we probably wouldn't fund it.
But one of the things is, all right,
it's potato chips, what more can you do?
Now, you look at the last 10 years and
well, look at Pringles, right?
They built a really big company,
I think,
I actually don't know how big they are.
They built a big company but
it's primarily a marketing challenge.
In software, there’s some things
that are also mature markets.
So CRM, right.
Customer Relationship Management
software.
It's actually a pretty mature market.
Now Salesforce disrupted it, in a lot
ways, to build a very large company.
And there’s still things
that can be done.
But it takes something
really insightful and
really new to figure how to build
the next great CRM company.
And I think there will be more of them.
It's a lot harder.
Not to say it's a bad idea but
it takes a little more thinking and
a little more, I think,
a much deeper insight.
Some newer markets that
are really immature.
One that I like to think about, drones.
>> Drones.
>> Everyone likes to talk about them but
I think it was something like
500,000 drones were sold last year.
And the market's growing by some
ridiculous percentage every single year.
That is such an underdeveloped market,
and
we think about all the applications
that drone have yet to touch.
It's kind of mind-boggling.
I mean we're talking everything
from crop analysis, right.
Flying a drone over a field which they
typically do with fixed-wing aircraft
now, just to see how healthy crops are,
all the way to tracking shots in movies.
There's all these things and
we don't know what that's going to do.
Not to mention unmanned
drones giving the Internet
to places which Facebook and Google are
both working on, or transporting people.
>> Right.
>> I don't know.
>> That's going to be cool.
>> It's going to be really cool.